in the last video i introduced you to
the idea of the chain rule with partial
derivatives and we said well if i have a
if i have a function psi
greek letter psi is a function of x and
y
and if i wanted to take the partial of
this with respect to no i want to take
the derivative not the partial the
derivative of this with respect to x
this is equal to the partial of psi
with respect to x plus
the partial of psi
with respect to y times d y d x
and in the last video i didn't prove it
to you but i hope it gave you a little
bit of intuition that you you couldn't
believe me but maybe one day i'll prove
it a little bit more rigorously but you
can find prusan on the web if if you are
interested for the the chain rule with
partial derivatives so let's put that
aside and let's explore another property
of partial derivatives and then we're
ready to
get the intuition behind exact equations
because what you're going to find it's
very it's fairly straightforward to
solve exact equations but the intuition
is a little bit more
well i don't want to say it's difficult
because if you have the intuition you
have it
so
what if i had to say the same functions
i and i were to take the partial
derivative of it of psi with respect to
x first
i'll just write psi i don't have to
write x and y every time
and then i were to take the partial
derivative
with respect
to
y
so just as a notation
this you could write as
you could kind of view it as you're
multiplying the operator so it could be
written like this the partial del
squared
times psi or del squared psi
over
del y
del or curly dx
and that can also be written as and this
is my preferred notation because it
doesn't have all this extra junk
everywhere you could just say well the
partial we took the partial with respect
to x first so this just means the
partial of psi with respect to x and
then we took the partial with respect to
y
so that's one situation to consider what
happens when we take the partial with
respect to x and then y so with respect
to x you hold y constant
to get just the partial with respect to
x ignore the y there and then you hold
the x constant and you take the partial
with respect to y
so what's the difference between that
and if we were to switch the order so
what happens if we were to i'll do it in
a different color if we had psi
and we were to take the partial
with respect to y first
and then we were to take the partial
with respect to
x
so just the notation just you're
comfortable with it
that would be so partial x partial y
and this is you know this is the
operator and that's it might be a little
confusing that here the between these
two notations even though the same thing
the order is mixed
that's just because it's just a
different way of thinking about it this
says okay partial first with respect to
x then y this views it more as the
operator so we took the partial of x
first and then we took y like you're
multiplying the operators but anyway so
this can also be written as
the partial of y
with respect to
sorry the partial of y and then we took
the partial of that with respect to x
now i'm going to tell you right now that
if each of the first partials are
continuous and most of the functions
we've dealt with in the in you know in a
normal domain as long as there aren't
any discontinuities or holes or
something strange in the function
definition they usually are continuous
and especially in a first year calculus
or differential course we're probably
going to be dealing with continuous
functions in in our domain if both of
these functions are continuous if both
of the first partials are continuous
then
these two are going to be equal to each
other
so
psi
of x y is going to be equal to psi of y
x
now we can use this knowledge
which is the chain rule using partial
derivatives
and
this knowledge to now solve
a certain class of differential
equations
first order differential equations
called exact equations and what does an
exact equation look like
an exact equation looks like this
it's always the color picking is hard
part so let's say i have
this is my differential equation i have
some function of x and y
so you know i don't know it could be x
squared times cosine of y or something i
don't know it could be any function of x
and y plus some function of x and y
we'll call that n
times d y d x d y d x is equal to 0.
this is well i don't know it's an exact
equation yet but if you saw something of
this form
your your first impulse should be oh
well actually your very first impulse is
is this separable and you should try to
play around with the algebra a little
bit and see if it's separable because
that's always the most straightforward
way if it's not separable but you can
still put in this form you say hey isn't
it the exact equation and what's an
exact equation well look immediately
this pattern right here
this pattern right here looks an awful
lot like this pattern
right what if m was the partial of psi
with respect to x what if
psi
with respect to x is equal to m
right what if this was psi with respect
to x and what if this was psi with
respect to y
so psi with respect to y is equal to n
what if i'm just saying we don't know
for sure right if you just if you just
see this someplace randomly you won't
know for sure that this is the partial
of with respect to x of some function
and this is the partial with respect to
y of some function but we're just saying
what if
if this were true
then we could rewrite this as the
partial of z with respect to x plus the
partial of psi with respect to y
times d y
d x
equal to zero
and this right here the left side right
there that's the same thing as this
right this is just the derivative of psi
with respect to x
using the partial derivative chain rule
so you could rewrite it
you could rewrite this is just
the derivative of psi with respect to x
as i is a function of x y
is equal to zero
so if
if you look at you see a differential
equation it has this form and you're
saying boy that you know i can't
separate it but maybe it's an exact
equation and frankly if you know that
that was what was recently covered in
you know in a before the the current
exam it probably is an exact equation
but if you see this form you say boy
maybe it's an exact equation if it is an
exact equation and i'll show you how to
test it in a second using this
information
then this can be written as the
derivative of some function
psi
right where this is the partial of psi
with respect to x this is the partial of
psi with respect to y
and then if you could write it like this
and you take the derivative of both
sides i'm sorry you take the
antiderivative of both sides and you
would get psi
of xy
is equal to c as the solution
so there are two things that we should
be caring about that you might be saying
okay sal you've you've kind of you know
you've walked through size and partials
and all this
what is it one how do i know that it's
an exact equation and then if it is an
exact equation which tells us that there
is some psi then how do i solve for the
psi
so the way to
figure out isn't an exact equation is to
use this information right here
we know that if psi and its derivatives
are continuous over some domain
that the when you take the partial with
respect to x and then y that's the same
thing as taking as doing it in the other
order so we said this is the partial
with respect to x right this is the
partial with respect to x
and this is the partial with respect to
y
so if this is an exact equation
if this is the exact equation if we were
to take the partial of this with respect
to y
right if we were to say if we were to
take the partial of m with respect to y
so
the partial of psi with respect to x is
equal to m
if we were to take the partial of those
with respect to y so we could just
rewrite that as that
then that should be equal to the partial
of n
with respect to x right
the partial of psi with respect to y is
equal to n
so if we take the partial with respect
to x of both of these
take the partial with respect to x we
know from this that these should be
equal if psi and its partials are
continuous over that domain so then this
will be
this will also be equal so that is
actually the test to test if this is an
exact equation so let me rewrite all of
that again and summarize a little bit so
if you see something of the form
m
of x y
plus n
times d y
d x is equal to zero
and then you take the partial derivative
of m with respect to y
of n with respect to x and they are
equal to each other
then
and it's actually if and only if it goes
both way this is an exact equation
an exact differential equation this is
an exact equation and if it's an exact
equation that tells us that there exists
a psi
such that
the derivative
of
psi of x y
is equal to zero or psi of x y
is equal to c is a solution of this
equation and
the partial derivative of psi with
respect to x
is equal to m
and the partial derivative of psi with
respect to y is equal to
n and i'll show you in the next video
how to actually use this information to
solve for psi so here are some things i
want to point out this is going to be
the partial derivative of r as i with
respect to x but when we take the kind
of exact test we take it with respect to
y because we want to get that mixed
derivative
similarly this is going to be the
partial derivative of psi with respect
to
y but when we do the test we take the
partial of it with respect to x so we
get that mixed derivative
this is with respect to y and then with
respect to x so you get this
anyway i know that might be a little bit
involved but if you understood
everything i did i think you'll have the
intuition behind why the methodology of
exact equations works i will see you in
the next video where we will actually
solve some exact equations see you soon